hey I'm Doug Walker from channel awesome
at the end of our most popular show
nostalgia critic we always do a charity
shout-out encouraging people to donate
well they've done well we realize not
everybody's in a financial situation
where they can give but everybody at
some point or another can give time so
every month we're gonna try and show a
new charity or organization that you can
help out with there's so many people in
difficult circumstances but thankfully
there's always people who are willing to
help and you can be one of them
well there's volunteering or lending a
helping hand we're here to show you what
you can do okay so this episode is gonna
be a little different because the
charity we are doing this month is build
they're located in Chicago and today
they're doing a peace parade as well as
a carnival this is an organization that
engages at-risk children and we were
going to talk to these people at this
incredible event where they can learn
about cams summer jobs and over 50
social service providers business and
elected officials it was gonna be this
huge deal but there's one problem this
is the day it was supposed to happen
so the parade has been moved to August
the nice thing is this gives you plenty
of time to possibly attend and see all
the great work that they do but the
downside is all the future charities we
have for the show are planned months in
advance and we're still gonna do one in
August we're gonna go to the event and
we're gonna film it we're gonna see all
this incredible stuff but it's a little
late to get another charity now so we're
still gonna do bill today we're just
gonna do more of like a charity shout
out to show a lot of good that they do
and like I said if you can make it to
this parade if you can make it to this
carnival definitely show up this is only
their second year and the first year
went wonderful you should really see the
great things that they're doing there so
with that said we're just gonna give you
some information on what a wonderful
organization this is and what you can do
to help build grows hope and engagement
with a wide array of school and
community-based programs that build the
habits of success spark interests
uncover talents give kids a sense of
accomplishment and empower them with the
two
to resist risky behavior and make
positive choices their mission is to
engage at-risk youth in schools and on
the streets so they can realize their
educational and career potential and
contribute to the stability safety and
well-being of our communities founded in
1969 as a pioneering gang intervention
program build is nationally recognized
as a gang intervention violence
prevention and youth development
impacting over 3000 youth and families
in five Chicago's most challenged
communities built holistic model
integrates an array of services to meet
individual and community needs including
gang intervention violence prevention
college and career readiness youth
leadership development and civic
engagement entrepreneurship the arts and
clinical services their objective is to
ensure that every child has a bright
future regardless of individual
challenges or neighborhood barriers if
you look at their site on their YouTube
page you can see all the creative ways
they help kids find a future where they
can thrive and succeed they have tons of
events you can visit donate to or
volunteer at on their site and like I
said they got that great peace parade
and carnival coming up in August so you
should definitely show up there if you
can click on the link and see how you
can play a big part in keeping the
future peaceful and strong
[Music]
you